[Music]
so by way of intro I'm Alan aim I'm on
the product management team at Google I
work on Google kubernetes engine and
these days I've been spending most of my
time working on how to bring google
kubernetes engine outside of Google
cloud primarily on premise hi I'm grace
I'm a cloud solutions architect and as
part of my role I get to talk to lots of
customers and I'm looking for repeating
patterns that I can then figure out how
to share those learnings where I
solutions and tutorials okay
so Alan I'm here to actually talk to you
about why customers moving to the cloud
okay so I'm going to talk about a subset
of our customers financial services
customers so why they moving to the
cloud it's not because it's a fad it's
because they've got some solid reasons
as you can see as to why they'd want to
do this so one of the key ones fresh out
the door tends to be agility I sit down
and they start saying they want to be
more agile they want their developers to
be able to experiment without them
having to kind of invest in upfront
capex they're also in a lot of cases
their network isn't actually designed
for global collaboration and global
delivery so I'll see they think oh the
cloud will help them to do that and I'll
see with a scale of gtp that will
obviously help them and then they've got
over the time they've had lots of
problems with single points failure
because the way things have developed so
they're thinking about how they can
actually provide better availability and
because when you design for the cloud we
actually kind of encourage you to think
about failures up front because things
fade all the time and then there's the
cost optimization which they also kind
of key so some of the workloads this
upset them think about our risk and
regulatory reporting they've got more
and more data and rules that they need
to comply with so they want to do lots
of analytics and big data type crunching
so things they need to prove
actually doing as they say then there's
financial risk modeling lots of CPU and
they're also always developing new
consumer applications so Greece you're
out there talking to a lot of customers
and having conversations around their
cloud journey what are some of the
challenges that you're seeing out there
I'm gonna ask that ok so that's been
financial services one of the first
thing out the door is regulations ok
they're global so not only they got to
add a with regulations for local regions
but also global regulations and as well
as just regulation so you've got I speak
to all the teams that have an influence
and actually use the platform so let's
have a look at what the infrastructure
teams tend to require they have locality
concerns as well so two types is the
workload some of the workloads can be
run on premises some can be run on the
cloud in addition to that they've got
where can this work in your data be they
want to be able to classify their data
because they can at some place if they
just cannot move that data to the cloud
and even when it's gets to the cloud
it's like oh hang on a minute we're in
the cloud can it be so they won't
actually pin it to a region and you know
when that date and moves up they also
want to be able to do identify it
they're also very very concerned about
the fact that they've got to run this
their operations across a hybrid
platform so they're worried about the
technical technical complexity of that
so I spoke earlier about the single
points of failure so it's all about
business continuity ok so the fact that
they want their infrastructure and their
application interfaces to be designed
and built for resiliency and also they
want to make sure that they're caused to
those interfaces are authenticated and
authorized they want to have logical
separation they want to be able to
distinguish between workloads and team
projects ok then they want guardrails
basically they want to be able to
propagate rules from the organisation
downwards without getting in the way of
their developers so they want to
mitigate against potential human error
they want to actually stop near the URLs
having unauthorized access and they want
to be able to get signals for all of
this they want to be able to
monitor that hybrid architecture whether
it be on platform or on prep or in the
cloud sorry yep and there's consistency
of the infrastructure and the policies
that apply across both platforms the
security team have also got very similar
requirements as well they also want to
be able to classify data and they have
issues around where certain data should
be they want to be able to integrate
their security controls as part of their
pipeline deployment be that whether its
infrastructure is code to actually
deploy to the actual undecided to the
outer infrastructure or whether its
application codes they want those
controls to be part of NC as part I've
earned those that deployment and they
want it to be a first-class citizen data
integrity they want to make sure they're
secure access to data and they also want
to prevent one thing they there's a
common ask it's like okay once we've got
our data in the cloud can we prevent it
being modified for a set period of time
auditing going here they want to be a
you know the actual active auditing
shouldn't change anything
forensic auditing and they obviously
been able to track who's doing what and
their platform is key
separation of duty lease privilege it's
actually two sides of the same coin it's
all about permissions so if you think
about the fact that you bar that you
have essential security or network team
that infers you don't want other teams
to have those the ability to change your
firewall rules or other security
controls so it's making sure people have
the permissions they need to do their
job and just and not over permissioning
organization-wide policies that's
essentially the guardrails in the
infrastructure team talked about and of
course there's developers all right so
developers as we said they want to but
they want that they want to be more
agile we want to improve the speed of
deployment and one of the things that's
come up and about this is the fact that
people started to adopt micro services
because it allows you to work on bits of
your application and without that with
using different teams and they don't get
in each other's ways because they can
actually independently update that
service they can independently scale and
kubernetes has been seen as a way to do
that because
the commanding on-prem you can run it in
another cloud you can run it on us
separation of duty again that's all
about who can do what and here they're
really concerned about separating out
the operational requirements from the
development requirements okay logical
separation here is isolation between
environments and that can mean between
different different services or it can
mean between dev prod and QA and then
there's isolation between those
workloads and services developers they
love see ICD tooling so one of the
things that they want is to actually
have the same tooling deploy to
whichever platform be that on premise or
on the cloud and they want consistency
they want to be able to have one way of
signaling and through audit audit
auditing the Reformation login and
alerting and we're hoping that you're
going to be able to actually help us
unblock some of these these are pretty
big shoes to fill so what better way to
truly understand you know all these
various requirements that grace has
walked through them to actually hear it
from a customer directly and I have the
privilege of inviting Raja
Rea from Macquarie Bank to come up on
stage and and talk about how they've
accomplished some of these challenges so
you know I've been working with Raja
here for a couple of months and I've
been super impressed just the level of
agility that his teams have brought
across the entire organization helping
their teams to be able to deploy upwards
between sixty to a hundred deploys per
day and that's fantastic sera jey
without further ado thank you very much
Alan so today I'm gonna take you through
a high-level view of what we do in
Macquarie Bank and before that let me
just quickly take a two through who
Macquarie Bank ease so Macquarie Bank is
has a presence in about 27 countries we
are global bank and one of the largest
infrastructure managers and in fact one
of the largest infrastructure asset
managers in the world we have over about
fifteen thousand employees in Macquarie
there are five key divisions in
Macquarie I work in banking and
financial services which is the retail
arm of the business
I look after digital engineering in the
bank at the moment so we are digital
Bank which means we have no branches
absolutely no branches the only branch
we have right now is one branch which is
in Shelli Street at in Sydney that's
where our head office is about four and
a half five years ago we started a
journey and when we started that journey
our objective was to create highly
consumable interactions for our
customers how do we do that how do we
take complex data and make them more
consumable and more meaningful for our
customers that was the idea there's an
example here this is my account actually
where you could go and say using natural
language search capabilities you could
say how much did I spend in golf around
longer I'll play a lot of golf and you
can see there you know it's we have
proximity based search and if I have a
bad day I end up in tauntaun Li which is
on your left there's a red dot there
that's where I go and kind of try and
you know improve my my swing on the left
side we've got an example of of insights
over sides and four sites about four
years ago we didn't have a mobile
presence today we do and it's a leading
experience at the moment in Australia I
mentioned we're a digital bank and we
are also providing white label solutions
for clients we have over around 50
different channels that we support today
that tells you the complexity the level
of complexity that we have to face in
managing our entire ecosystem I went
back to about five years ago this is
where we were I'm sure all of you can
relate to this active-passive
infrastructure and you know would take
us about six to eight hours to deploy
beautiful infrastructure you can see
that there lots of monolithic
applications it took us a while and then
we said you know if we are to be a
digital Bank there's no way we could
survive in a world where everything is
changing constantly so we are living in
the
Industrial Revolution where we know that
it's all about the fast that beats a
slow and connectivity is near oil T so
how do you ship software in minutes
that's really really important as an
organization we need to find a way to
help the organization move faster and
your software has to be shippable how do
we do that this is how we've done this
this is a the evolution that we've been
on from the right from their their left
side you will see we started with
monolithic applications moved on to mic
receive a C's after that we moved all
our data to a data platform which I'll
explain in more detail in the next slide
experimentation is important in order to
be you know really innovative you've got
to be able to learn and innovate fast
hence we'll talk about that in terms of
architecture how do we align with that
how do we complement what the business
wants to do cloud was important moving
to the cloud was fundamental for us and
of course with all of this we were the
first bank in Australia to publish open
api's and we did this last year early
last year that's the pace of innovation
that we have at the moment so we went
form being having the ability to
sequentially release which is maybe once
in a month or once in three months to
something like sixty to a hundred
releases a day and we do this actively
in production I'll talk a little more
about that our UIs would take roughly 30
seconds to deploy and I can tell you
about that as well this is our currency
it architecture today from the bottom
we've got the system of record we're
publishing all our events to lay above
and then we've that's where your
enterprise data is deep down in the
enterprise about that we have in the
data Enterprise internet Enterprise
Theatre which is stored in a datastore
layer all running on kubernetes this is
where we have Cassandra SPARC solar
elasticsearch Kafka in-memory data
stores spark for in-memory processing
data has no end no beginning right now
so it cannot fit in memory so we
got to find a way to process this
continuously we have Redis as well and
we consciously made a decision to run
all our data our data services in a
separate cluster and the reason is very
simple you have different challenges
when you think about networks you have
no diapies that need to be exposed you
have to think about backup strategies
how do you do that at scale using arc
you got terabytes and terabytes of data
how do you do that you gotta think
differently in fact we started a journey
three years ago so we've been investing
upstream with various technologies and
strategies our through partners to
enable us to do this at scale we also
have graph databases that we use for
customer 360 and permissions and
entitlements that we have above that
layer you've got the digital services or
stateful it's applications we've
separated the concerns we're constantly
rebuilding our applications from source
platforms are torn down every 60 days we
have to roll it over and with that we
have to roll all the traffic over so if
you're supporting imagine if you're
supporting more than 50 different
channels it's a highly complex exercise
to have all this done in a unified
manner so we have the API management
gateway which is Appaji we've been
partnering with Google for a long time
now almost four years with Apogee and
the data the traffic shaping is done
from the apogee layer on top and above
that we've got open endpoint
independence which means we we believe
in co-creating value in the ecosystem
that's the reason why we published open
api's and we have a single strategy for
all our consumers it's open I be open I
do connect with or author - and you can
see there we have other consumers as
well Salesforce which is our internal
client in our internal staff is using
that for a customer support new partners
we also have a partners building their
own experiences with IEP ice and we have
to do this at scale with all our
services changing continuously
multiple times a day how do we do that
so we've fairly you know an outside-in
based architecture approach with
everything we do we think about
customers first and then start building
our solutions now because we have this
architecture which is on the cloud
running on kubernetes we can spin up
multiple environments every developer
can have an end-to-end environment and
you can see there we snap all your data
that's being published and all the
events that are coming through almost
real-time we split that up and we can
create an end-to-end environment saying
hey only our digital engineers can
access this this area so we control the
blast radius of the access in that area
and it's all live in production right so
it's like saying I got a mini production
environment running and I can have a few
of these running depending on the
features that we are trying to build
because this is all about accelerating
our path to production now I believe
Netflix published some kind of a paper
on this and they call this forklifting
of how not a mistaken then once you're
happy with that we move over to beta
beta is where we constantly you know
working with our partners we were
working with our internal staff and of
course we invite external clients to
also come and comment and give us
feedback continuously lastly of course
once that's done we can move to
production this is really important this
is a strategy that's the secret sauce
that makes us successful and we have to
innovate really fast coming to how we
did this I'll quickly tell you about you
know how we've implanted implemented
this and how we industrialized
communities so we've got kubernetes
running of course and where do you dry
out where you have to think in terms of
where do you draw the line between what
a platform team should be doing and what
the product team should be doing so of
course you have communities if you are
just one or two teams you wouldn't have
to worry too much about you know
shipping software out but if you have
let's say about 40 teams like we do and
over hundreds and hundreds of developers
you have to think differently about how
do you industrialize this we are a
highly regulated environment
we are regulated we are we have
obligations for regulators hence we have
to make sure that everything is traced
nor dated so we use get-ups all our all
our governance related parameters and
metadata are stored in gate and if you
guys are not aware of gear ops have a
search on the internet and you'll learn
a lot more about it it's a very
interesting topic essentially we can
store all our metadata in git and you
can have approvals and everything done
using git itself so this is where you
have permissions based on hey there's
this is the structure of the team within
this team this is the release manager
this is the approver this is how you get
stuff into production if your release
manager you can only get stuff into
production using the JIRA you can't go
and deploy it from anywhere else you
have to have security boundaries drawn
up very clearly and this is why you have
to look at guardrails that are really
important it could be detective could be
preventive you have to think about that
another thing that really really
challenged us when we went in town the
kuben is route was you end up with 50
necks density right everybody is
deploying software in development in
test and you are running over capacity
all the time so you're the manager
capacity of to manage the expiry of
these namespaces and that itself is a
challenge we have user access reviews
which again you know being regulated we
have to produce all of that now moving
further up you think in terms of secret
management at the moment we have our
strategy for managing or a secrets and a
certificates that's homegrown and we're
now moving towards hashing coke Walt if
you had 50 ways of doing this you would
not be able to industrialize this it
will be a nightmare so what we do is we
have a standard pattern in place we have
standard API is in place that delivers
list for us so for us to shift over to
the vault would be really really very
simple another good example here would
be how do you handle vulnerabilities we
practice signal ops our security team
are building all the
he is on top of all the scanners and
they handle all the false positives as
you all know it's a nightmare
think in terms of how do you manage
whole bald spot it's positives it's
almost impossible to do that
so we do there ourselves and our entire
eco system we built onto our eco system
on top of kubernetes to enable us to do
this at speed and scale as you move up
you know as I move up this is this is
what we're trying to say here we try to
absorb all the responsibilities from the
developers right all the platform
related responsibilities anything that
we're repeating if we are doing anything
once or twice we try and group if it's
repeatable we try and absorb that into
the platform about 98% of the patterns
that we have are all reusable so here
you see the lines going further and
further up and we want to move the line
of innovation closer and closer to the
developers so they only have one job and
one job alone and that is to create
world-class experiences for our
customers and the last thing I'd like to
say there is you know when you when you
think in terms of scale here and we are
constantly moving our clusters
recreating them you got to bleed the
traffic over to the latest services so
what we do is match our platform allows
us to match clusters match namespaces
match services within clusters using
synthetics and then once we are ready we
flick the traffic's across so this is
happening continuously during the day in
fact we do not do any releases a night
we do it live everything we do is life
as a bank you know it's quite
challenging to get there but we've got
there because we're on the cloud today
so the next thing I'd like to say here
is this is an example a quick example of
how we route our traffic we have let's
say white label partners building their
own solutions you know using version 1.5
where's room 1.8 of all our or our
services and api's you'd have Macquarie
Bank 20 to 1.7 and let's say you had a
bug you would say I want to create 1.8
you're gonna drop that in it'll take you
about five minutes what we do is build
products
namespace related to a product so let's
say you got personal banking namespace
you'd have a wealth namespace and
identity namespace a business banking a
namespace and so on so forth and you'll
find most of the time you know your
applications your architecture your
topology of your namespaces would always
always reflect the way you build your
software in the organization and it's a
fact you will be doing that and if you
do that it's a challenge but we'll come
to that challenge as well now what we do
here is also you could just drop in or
change any any microt service here what
we prefer to do is move them as a set as
a as a set or as a product through the
entire lifecycle from development right
through you know integration unit
testing and production lab and
production our new features as I
mentioned before we have no limit to the
number of nodes you want to create we
have multiple clusters we have different
classes for different purposes
Enterprise Services legacy applications
we have you know digital services
stateful stateless you name it we have
it and we have multiple such
environments and you have to do this
constantly so having said that we're now
releasing to production almost 60 to 100
times a day so what does it mean for us
what's next for us and this is
interesting we have spent a lot of
effort in the past three years managing
kubernetes it's not an easy task it's
not for the faint-hearted
and we've also been curating from
upstream and bringing it in we we
actually working with partners upstream
and it's a challenge for us what we want
to do is outsource all this
responsibility to Google we want to make
sure that we are focusing wholly and
solely on one thing alone which is
building business value for our
customers and our partners now if you
think about what makes for us I talked
about how we are building our software
today it's fairly siloed we try we have
products right let's here business
banking world and personal banking and
now you want
you know you want to start creating
services that can be shared this is
where the challenge comes so you build a
you build a namespace and you say this
is a payment gate this is the payment
gateway for all the products and then
you start thinking in terms of hey I
need to worry about the services to
service interactions I need to start
thinking about east-west interactions
rather than not South that's what we do
a lot we have a lot of API
you know API we use a lot of the API
gateway with the authentication and
authorization what also happens in our
current state architecture is we happen
to have all sorts of patterns of
authentication or authorization spanned
across all our services we have defense
by depth of course but just to manage
that is a huge overhead a lot of
animation goes in a lot of energy goes
and we expend a lot of effort in trying
to do this efficiently so we would love
to have one control plane we'd love to
simplify that entire architectures so we
can enable our teams to morph into more
feature based development we want the
the flexibility to move faster and
faster and we believe that that's
slowing us down at the moment so we are
excited to be working with Google and
you know what's it called again
it's anthos I'm still getting used to it
it just got announced today so I I
remember it as CSP so excited to work
with Google on this we are hoping that
you know you continue to curate
technology from upstream bring it to us
make it in price grade and any price
Radian we can focus on what we do best
which is business building the business
value for customers lastly I like to say
that you know we at Macquarie continue
to aspire to dream in months planning
days and ship in minutes I'm around here
after this meeting if there's any other
questions I'm happy to take them thank
you very much
Thank You Roger
so we we designed Antos really to cater
to the needs of enterprise customers
like Macquarie so the example that Rajai
walked through is very much the area
that we're looking at addressing with an
to us so that as customers you can
outsource a lot of the complexities
associated with managing these
environments and being able to implement
centralized governance across
environments that are very heterogeneous
in nature but do it in a way that's
predictable and consistent that's really
what anthos is about so today we
announced anthos it's the latest
innovation from Google it's a surround
hybrid and multi cloud computing it's
for modernizing applications automating
policy and it provides you security at
scale and it'll run on Prem in Google
Cloud and other clouds so part of the
challenge with hybrid traditionally has
been you know hybrid is complex right
when you start thinking about deploying
applications across multiple
environments start addressing challenges
around operational overhead and costs
because you're having to use many
different tools and bring in people of
different skill sets and it's not just
about the technology it's about the
people and process right that's
complicated in terms of how you make all
that happen kubernetes did a really good
job but abstracting away the underlying
infrastructure and we're all happy about
that just show of hands how many people
out here are using kubernetes it's
awesome in kubernetes has done a very
good job there but as you start building
more and more containerized applications
and exposing services and services that
live on prem in the cloud on other
clouds how do you manage all these
interactions how do you implement a
preventive preventive policy cross who
can do what and what applications are
allowed to do across this environment
these are really hard things to do and
then getting started with kubernetes
typically you know cloud providers do a
very good job at providing managed
kubernetes implementations but what if
what
you have to get started outside of cloud
right there's tens 20 30 distributions
out there each is different well what if
you had an ability to get a Google
supported Google distribution of
kubernetes which is Google kubernetes
engine and pretty much run it anywhere
starting with on-prem and that's what
we've done with Antos we've provided a
gke on-prem distribution that you can
run in your data centers that's fully
consistent with gke in the cloud so that
you can build applications for one
environment and be able to run them
anywhere and then let's not forget about
operations right the day to experience
right the ability to be able to define
central policy and apply these policies
across all of your cluster environments
in a consistent fashion
Rajai mentioned the whole notion of git
ops right this is our goal with ant us
it's really to drive the git offs model
so you can check your policy and config
and to get and have them applied
deterministically across your cluster
environments regardless of where they're
running and then we're providing a
centralized monitoring and logging
framework via stag driver and prometheus
for your entire operations for your
hybrid environments as well so let's
talk about how GCP and anthis can help
you grace you start off the presentation
talking about all the challenges that
you're seeing out there so let's walk
through these challenges and talk about
how we address them so grace started off
talking about regulation right customers
operate in a very regulated environment
Google Cloud has achieved independent
verification of security privacy and
compliance controls achieving
certification against global standards
so that's done now let's talk about
infrastructure requirements so anthos
enables platform operators to
consistently run and centrally manage
their kubernetes clusters across on-prem
and the cloud this includes gke on-prem
that i just talked about which is a
keh distribution that runs on premise on
top of that an to us provides
centralized management for your
kubernetes clusters and services now
these services could be container based
or you could have a virtual machine that
has an envoy proxy that now becomes part
of the service mesh but you now have the
ability to centralize centrally manage
this environment across on-prem and
public cloud and the important thing is
reducing the operational overhead of
operating across this hybrid environment
that's key that's been one of the
biggest adoption blockers is the
complexity and the operational costs our
aim is to reduce that for applications
that have data sensitivity and locality
concerns Google clouds data loss
prevention API can be used to classify
data to ensure that it remains or gets
set where it's allowable so we have
sessions this week on the DL PAP I
highly recommend you check into that and
there's also a booth that you can learn
more about it
Antos has been designed from the ground
up to manage hybrid resources and we
enable you to configure policies so that
you meet the standards around your
business continuity that's been very key
for us platform operators can logically
separate workloads and teams either
using clusters or namespaces the idea
here is kubernetes you know as you start
using it you have to make important
decisions around UI create one cluster
for all my teams do I have a cluster per
team do I create a namespace per team
we're providing all the various tooling
to enable you to make the choice you
have freedom of choice around what model
works for you but then define config
across all these environments in a
consistent fashion and a common unifying
monitoring and logging service across
your hybrid environments really that
minimizes the risk with exposing
services now let's talk about the
security team requirements so Antos
allows you to run your workloads and
have your data reside where you need it
and again this is where DLP comes in
where you can classify your data ensure
that data does
and up were in places it shouldn't and
then you can leverage existing see ICD
tooling to implement container supply
chain and and implement things like
image scanning binary authorization and
so forth across your container supply
chain and you get real-time visibility
right think of sto as real-time
monitoring for your services you're
getting real-time visibility and
integrated logging across your services
that are running in this hybrid
environment now the cool thing here is
really around configuration management
and centralized governance so Antos
brings this notion of git ops into
reality so you've heard from Roger you
know for the last couple years they've
been developing this environment really
that's very good Ops driven we want to
bring get ops to the masses right so
that you can just take advantage of it
from day one and the idea here is really
bringing to reality this whole notion of
separation of concerns you know at
Google we operate in a model where we
have cluster operators application ops
and security admins really operating
independently but working together and
we're bringing this model of separation
of concerns so the so that
administrators can define preventative
policies that can be centrally defined
and propagated across the hybrid
environment that's really key for us so
anthos configuration management enables
cluster security network admin teams to
operate independently and define
configuration centrally and
configuration can be owned by these
independent teams and it really
decouples the infrastructure and
security concerns away from the
development team that's really the idea
here you can start small you can have
every team go and build out their own
environment you can define these
policies and configs for each one of
these environments then you can
centrally govern them over time so that
you're not introducing friction from the
start
developers are super critical for us our
goal here is to enable developers to
move fast really when you think about it
and
as a platform for agile development it's
it's not in a sense opinionated to the
point where developers can't do what
they feel comfortable in doing but it
provides a framework to enable
developers to interact with the rest of
the broader team in a way that's
frictionless right and the idea is to
enable developers to be able to deploy
applications transparently into these
multiple environments that look very
different and then finally you know we
have services that we built at Google to
really make the life of applications
DevOps easier things like cloud build
that are tightly integrated with our
container supply chain you know we
provide these as add-ons for Antos but
will work with any CI CD tool that's
there on the market to provide a great
experience and really the goal here is
around consistency and ensuring that
you're not spending time learning
different tools for different
environments so that that sounds great
so let me just summarize what you've
just kind of spoke to me about it's the
fact that your can telling me that I can
actually up get rid of all the
operational craft so that I can have a
single pane of glass to manage both on
Prem and in the cloud oh that's so cool
and also that I can then just focus on
the business value which is cut
basically what won't be paid for and I
love the idea of the fact I can
segregate data you've mentioned various
ways that we can do that and it gives me
a solid foundation and room to grow as
Roger and show distance last earlier so
this sounds great but how do I get
started who wants to see a demo enough
talk let's see some of this in action so
I'm going to invite two Duke up on stage
to make this real hi everyone my name is
James Duke I'm in our professional
services group nicknamed the Duke like
Allen says I have the
challenging to us today of showing you
what this would actually look like in
practice so grace has told us thank you
for that all of the problems that we see
out there we've heard some Roger how
McCreary herself this and we've heard
from Alan how CSP solves this let's see
what that actually looks like in
practice so imagine the workflow you are
in financial services customer with your
business which I expect a number of you
out here already
and you now want to roll out some kind
of new service within your business
right whatever it might be for the
purposes of this demo I am going to use
a user demo which shows a very simple
application which is just grabbing data
from the pub/sub Google pub/sub API now
to actually release that what my target
ops process look like well the first
thing you would like you want to do is
review and update your security posture
and your guardrails that Roger mentioned
in order to accommodate their new
application so the place to do that is
going to be in a repository in this case
I'm going to use Google Cloud sauce
repositories to show you what that would
look like you were going their review
and update and submit that change at
that point in time any of the governance
process that you have would run we only
have ten minutes here so I'm gonna skip
the asking my manager for approval but
in theory you could put any of the
workflows in there you want then those
changes will then propagate out
automatically into all of the fleet and
all of the environments that are managed
by anthers finally I we can validate
those changes are in place and then
finally so as we've mentioned here
profit right at the end of the day this
is a tool to solve business problems and
so in order to do that what I'm going to
show you is the the use of a custom
resource definition and a company in
controller and what that does is the CID
or customer resource definition it
allows me to define something that
communities does not currently know
about all the anthos does not currently
know about the controller then allows me
to write the logic that translates that
resource definition into something that
kubernetes understands and it could be
anything for this case what we're going
to do is we're going to grant this app
access to the outside world and in order
to do that we will use a TCO rule so
along the top here you'll see
what it looks like conceptually and in
the bottom you'll see it what it is in
practice all right if we could switch
over the view you'll see here I have a
graph which is showing the traffic the
consumption from the pub/sub API for
this particular application as you can
see it's effectively zero the the peak
there is from this morning when I tested
this demo so what I'm going to do is
submit an actual change so you'll see
here in the logs deadlines exceeded
deadlines exceeded because the
application is unable to access the API
I am going to push this change into the
into the my git ops source of truth and
I'm going to add it I'm going to commit
I'm gonna call it allow access because
that's exactly what it does and then I'm
gonna push it into the source repo now
what that will do is take take my custom
resource definition and push it into my
repository then Google's configuration
management tool is going to pull the out
of the repo and push it out to all of
the clusters that are in in scope if I
show you the CID itself we can see what
it does so it is of type application
security boundary this is a custom type
that we have defined which specifies a
set of application security boundaries
it's called Y and it applies to the
namespace B lap one imagine we're an FSA
company we have many many different
namespaces doing many different things
this particular namespace is for a
particular type of application which is
doing brokering deals with third parties
from a marketplace and all I'm gonna do
is allow it access to Google api's with
protocol HTTP and port 443 then behind
the scenes config management is pushing
yourself now if i refresh my logs you
will see now I have the received be
received hello one received hello -
those are that's the traffic that is
being pushed into this pub/sub
subscription so now by pushing that one
cid into my git repo i have opened up
just for that namespace access to that
one particular set of API s--
kubernetes right so we can use the
hierarchy we can specify a namespace we
could do a global we can be quite
specific about it we can apply it to
specific name spaces in specific
security rings so imagine now that this
well this particular demo there is a on
prim component i've we've created such
the system in such a way as there are
two security tiers one of which
encompasses on-prem and cloud and one of
which is just on Prem so if I have those
particular workloads than I know I can't
push into the cloud I can keep them in
that that was work expect those
namespaces which are our security tiers
which are only on Prem now as you can
see that traffic is is appearing and as
you can see right on cue the the traffic
is spiking so that's a very trite
example right because all I've done is
really like for those of you familiar
with this do what I've already done is
create a service entry right however
think about this that CRD is not limited
to one thing it can incorporate almost
anything so what we are our goal here is
to be able to use to write these
templates and share them with you if we
could switch back to the slide space we
will have we will create a situation
where we produce these templatized CR DS
which we allow which we will then
publish to the world and the idea is
much is to solve Rogers point how could
if we were going to if they were going
to do this a second time how could we it
faster how could we lean on Google to
provide more of the best practices
out-of-the-box that I can consume very
easily so we would produce these
templates publish them in in github to
the world and they will allow you to
very very quickly bring these in and
build on top of them and grow them and
to make your adoption your your
migration to this process much much
faster on top of that Google
professional services so it's the team
I'm in and our partner organizations are
also putting together services packages
so we can help with this process so a
combination of smart trained people
sounds I'll just call myself smart there
doesn't know that sounds very bad
everybody else who's really small and me
are able to deliver these projects with
you by you by leaning on some of these
template template to see are these and
I'll go here is that this answers that
question of what do we want from CSP and
this is what it would look like it
breaks
all right thank you thank you James so
today we announced to anthos and we
invite you to come down to journey with
us if you're interested in evaluating it
test driving it please reach out to your
Google contact we think it's going to be
an exciting journey ahead and we welcome
your feedback and we look forward to
going down this journey with you over
the next several months
[Music]